[Music]
hi hi my name is p haard I'm from
Denmark uh I joined the European
Commission in 1993 that's almost 30
years ago but uh it's been extremely
interesting it's been an amazing ride
not a dull day in the office I've had
the privilege of um doing uh many many
different things right now I'm head of
representation of the European
Commission in Denmark before that I was
member of cabinet of President V Deion
before that I was a director in DG move
responsible for
transport uh before that I was head of
unit in the Secretary General dealing
with foreign policy and then I've also
been a spokesman dealing with
communication uh I've been in two
different cabinets um so
uh it's been very varied uh been doing
lots of different and very exciting and
very interesting
[Music]
things working for the European
commission has brought me uh three
things in particular first of all
responsibility working for the European
commission you represent one of the
largest economies in the world and
around 450 million people so what you do
on a daily basis really matters for
millions of people and millions of uh
Enterprises secondly there there are
always new challenges the European
commission is dealing with so many
different things so you can do a whole
range of different things always being
challenged and learning new things and
third your colleagues the most amazing
colleagues from all over Europe the
commission attracts the best and the
brightest from all over Europe so this
is very stimulating and it really makes
you learn new things every
[Music]
day working for the European commission
and working for the European Union means
working to promote values such as
Community democracy peace and security
and these are values which should not be
taken for granted during these very
difficult times in Europe where we have
a war going on so working for the
European commission means promoting
these values on a daily basis during
your
[Music]
work